these wow players did something so
controversial that University professors
studied it as the story goes all the way
back in 2006 a hord align Guild were
having an in-game funeral for one of
their members who died of a stroke in
real life her Guild chose a favorite
spot of hers in Winter Spring to gather
and pay their respects now reportedly
The Guild made the mistake of posting
about it on the Forum asking for people
for a moment of Peace while they held
their Gathering well unfortunately this
Alliance Guild Serenity Now either
didn't get the memo or chose to to
ignore it attacking the area and killing
the attendees Serenity Now ended their
video with quote sorry for your loss yes
we know we are smiley face now
technically they didn't break any
in-game rules it was PVP General social
rules decorum now that's what's up for
debate it's a nice gesture it's just
that it shouldn't have been done in a
contested Zone and that is exactly why
it was studied by actual academics at
the University of Melbourne it's very
interesting